[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de retour sur le plateau du 78 weekend
avec notre première invité Sylvie laouna
bonjour bonjour al en tant que
directrice d'ine tourisme vous venez
souvent sur notre plateau pour nous
donner quelques idées quelques conseils
de sortie les vacances de Noël démarrent
le le 21 vendredi 21 décembre alors
Sylvie qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
pendant cette période de vacan tout un
tas de choses très très variées on peut
commencer donc à partir du 22 euh à
faire une croisière de Noël euh au
départ de Conflant saint-onorine qui est
la capitale de la bâellerie et là sur la
croisière de Noël pour les enfants par
exemple on va découvrir les euh légendes
de Saint-Nicolas les légendes du Père
Noël et puis euh découvrir des moments
festifs sur un bateau et puis pour les
plus grands ça sera le le moment de de
boire du vin chaud de faire la fête sur
c'est très beau c'est tout illuminé là
et c'est un un endroit qui est
extrêmement dépaysan et pourtant euh
dans
c'est ça donc c'est vraiment une sortie
pour pour la famille d'autres idées
aussi en famille de sortiese comme ça
peti spectacle ce que je vais vous vous
présenter en fait ce sont que des idées
de famille c'est les vacances scolaires
donc on est c'est le moment où on se
retrouve en famille et surtout à Noël
alors là c'est un c'est un spectacle qui
va se dérouler au Haras des brevvières
c'est le 22 également le Haras des
brevvières c'est au Péré en en Yveline
c'est pas loin de rambouget et là le les
membres du ara vont faire découvrir les
légendes de Noël à l'occasion d'un
spectacle donc c'est pour les familles
après ça vous visitez les le merveilleux
endroit avec les les écuries et tout
tout ce qui a tras aux chevaux donc
c'est un moment à découvrir en famille
qui est vraiment exceptionnel donc un
spectacle équestre de Noë c'est un
spectacle équestre de Noël c'est ça et
puis si on veut un petit peu jouer si on
aime bien les jeux de société je pense
au jeu de loi comme ça oui voilà alors
le le jeu de loi mais instructif cette
fois-ci parce que c'est un un jeu de loi
qui va être proposé au
musée qui est devenu musée de de
l'antiquité nationale et ce musée de
l'antiquité nationale va proposer à
l'occasion de la de la visite qui est
une visite faite pour pour les jeunes un
grand tapis euh jeu de loi où vous
pouvez grâce à grandeur nature grâce à
des énigmes mieux connaître l'histoire
l'histoire du musée donc c'est tout à
fait ludique mais c'est aussi instructif
donc c'est les deux à la fois Ctait à
Saint-Germain en lait il y a 8 dates
c'est à partir du du
31 du 24 pardon décembre absolument et
c'est jusqu'au 6 janvier il y a 8 dates
en tout d'accord ou j'ai les antisèches
he 24 27 29 30 et 31 décembre et puis
ensuite en janvier trois dates les 3 5
et 6 janvier on passe j'ai envie d'aller
changer un petit peu d'environnement on
va la ville château verire alors
peut-être le château de Versailles non h
le plus grand que nous ayons dans les
ivelines puisque c'est le le le plus
grand le plus visité le plus connu euh
et là euh c'est la tasse de chocolat au
château de Versailles ça donne envie
super ah oui alors la tasse de chocolat
qu'est-ce que c'est que ce type de
visite et bien c'est dans le le château
des Trianons va découvrir euh la vie de
la contesse de Toulouse qui invitait ses
petits enfants ses enfants à venir
goûter euh donc on regarde un petit peu
comment ça se passait à l'époque à
travers les tableaux euh que l'on a dans
les dans les pièces en question et on
voit comment elle recevait ses enfants
ses petits- enfants à travers cette
merveilleuse porcelaine comment ça se
passait et c'est ça donne envie de se
retrouver à l'époque comme l'était ses
petits enfants ça c'est une visite qui
est réservée aux enfants le public
adulte aussi peut pe participer c'est
réservé aux familles effectivement et
les parents peuvent peuvent t'
acccompagner et faire la visite
parallèlement mais c'est les enfants qui
font ça est-ce qu'il y a une dégustation
alors de chocolat à l'issue de cette
visite
alors je vous parlerai de la dégustation
ensuite quand on parlera des salons de
thé mais c'est pas compris dans le dans
le dans la visite en question alors
ensuite on peut passer à un autre et
c'est le 27 décembre ah pardon la date
très important c'est juste le 27 oui
c'est juste le 27 décembre c'est très
très particulier voilà il faut pas il
faut pas le louper parce que il est pas
évident que tout ça se reproduise c'est
toujours pareil c'est exceptionnel donc
quand ça l'IT si on date la on loupe la
date après c'est fini un autre château
qui organise beaucoup d'événements pour
Noël c'est le château de Breteuil avec
des des ateliers couture oui des
ateliers créatifs de Sophie au château
de Breteuil le château de Breteuil c'est
un un château qui appartient au marquis
de Breteuil hein dont la famille est
assez célèbre enfin même très célèbre
dans l'histoire de France euh c'est dans
la vallée de Chevreuse et les enfants
vont apprendre à coudre euh à coudre des
éléments de euh de déguisement pour les
filles pour les garçons alors les filles
ça va être la j ex exactement ça fait
partie de ce que l'on peut se créer ou
alors le tutu de de fée la jupe de
princesse voilà ça c'est pour les filles
pour les gar garç c'est le col du Ché ou
la ceinture de chevalier la CAP de
Prince charm enfin voilà avec ah c'est
normal et on repart avec son déguisement
c'est bien quand même sinon et il ne
faut pas oublier quand même qu'il y a
toujours les conttes de pro que l'on
découvre toujours au château et qui
accompagne l'atelier créatif donc c'est
une bonne journée de découverte au
château pour pour les enfants et les
familles on continue dans les comptes
peut-être compte et histoire au château
de de maison maison Lafite voilà château
de maison Lafite qui lui est
complètement différent des deux autres
châteaux c'est un petit château qui est
parfois méconnu mais c'est un petit
bijou il est maintenant illuminé le soir
tiens bah voilà on le voit justement à
l'écran il est merveilleux illuminé il
les merveilleux de jour et là on va on
va découvrir le le château de manière
assez ludique encou en découvrant la vie
secrète la vie cachée un peu de de
l'époque et c'est ce qui est intéressant
parce que il y a la grande Histoire de
France et puis il y a toutes les petites
histoires qui intéressent un peu un peu
tout le monde et puis les familles en
sont particulièrement frayantes voilà
c'est en ça qu'il est différent ce
château par rapport aux autres vous
disait que le château de maison Lafite
était quand même différent il est
différent parce que d'abord il est plus
confidentiel il est beaucoup plus petit
ça n'a rien à voir avec le château de
versaill il est parfois méconnu euh le
château est aussi dédié au cheval
puisque c'est à maison la fite et que
c'est la capitale du cheval dans dans
les Yvelines il y a l'hippodrome voilà
donc il est il est différent par par ça
et puis il y a des petites pièces qui
sont pour moi des petites pièces bijoux
voilà vous m'avez mis en appétit tout à
l'heure avec cette tasse au chocolat
est-ce qu'on peut peut-être revenir dans
ce thème gastronomique oui oui alors les
salons de thé parce que évidemment quand
on se promène pendant les vacances de
Noël qu'on découvre tout un tas de
choses il fait pas très chaud en général
on est dehors et puis on se dit tiens
j'irais bien manger une petite
pâtisserie donc les salons de thé il y
en a par exemple dans le quartier
historique de Saint-Germain en lait
c'est le salon de thé d'Alice alors vous
pouvezer pour déjeuner pas seulement
pour pour le goûter au déjeuner vous
avez possibilité de manger des tartines
gourmandes des salades très très variées
et très originales et puis évidemment
les classiques pâtisseries qui peuvent
être d'origine autrichienne anglaise
américaine ou française donc il y en a
pour tous les goûts et effectivement ça
s'appelle le saloné d'Alice d'accord
donc ça c'est à Saint-Germain en lait
une autre adresse à marli Leroi oui
id nom on part en Angleterre c'est dans
en même temps pour un salon de thé ça
paraît logique c'est c'est souvent le
cas donc le cottage c'est dans la Grand
Rue de de marlye Leroi donc une petit
truc est très typique et c'est vraiment
un environnement très cosi très anglais
où là on découvre une cinquantaine de
thé il y a des animations qui se font
dans ce cottage sur tout un tas de
choses on peut découvrir les massages il
y a des animations pour la
Saint-Valentin enfin enfin tout un tas
d'animation puis évidemment on découvre
les pâtisseries
anglaises pancakes et puis muffin et
autres muffine anglais là je veux dire
il y a les Anglais américainsou et
Versailles alors dans tout ça Versailles
doit bien avoir un salon de thé quand
même ah bah Versailles il y en a
plusieurs même il y a la il y a celui de
de du château de
Versailles qui est le salon de tes dents
gelina qui est fort connu puisqu'il
existe déjà à Paris et puis dans les
grands magasins et donc il est rue de
Rivoli à Paris très connu pour son
chocolat avec sa petite crème fouettée
qui va bien avec et qui est
extraordinaire et alors là on on s assez
divin puis il y a les
pâtisseries avec le fameux gâteau
Montblanc foutsolum nous sur plateau des
petites démos des petites démos et
dégustations comme ça on donnera encore
plus envie et ça c'est au Pavillon
d'Orléan au premier étage une fois qu'on
a fini de visiter le château ou qu'on va
visiter le parc on se rem motion et on
fait des petites pâtisseries c'est bien
sympa et puis il y a aussi un salanté
dans versaill c'est rue de la paroiss
s'appelle l'or des mamans c'est pour les
maman seulement l'ORS des maman alors
l'ORS des mamans c'est pour les deux en
fait c'est pour maman enfant la maman
elle prend son petit thé l'enfant il
peut manger ses petits gâ auss il le
veut puis il y a des des livres pour
maman et des livres pour enfants comme
ça maman et enfant sont contents les
deux en même temps et puis partagent un
moment un petit peu un petit peu ludique
et un petit
peu comment instructif aussi puisqu'on
lit des livres donc c'est un bon moment
pour les deuxr voilà on se restaure et
on s'instruit on se réchauffe bah c'est
parfait merci beaucoup Syvie laouna pour
tous ces conseils